[Musique]
je suis content du résultat parce que
les vastes comme par une trentaine de
requins défendre un jeu super content
pour françois parce que parce qu'il a
super bien navigué que
l effort et c'est on s'est mis sur la
tronche
toute la saison
ça n'a pas loupé même si j'aurai un peu
plus au contact bon c'est comme ça et
voilà moi je vraiment content c'est une
bête transat la première étape la
victoire était hyper chouette là une 2e
place au général c
[Musique]
commencé à se ranger la mer là et qu'on
appelle transpire c'est génial c'est
génial ya eu avec deux jours là
quasiment où c'était du bonheur pur quoi
c'est savez pour qu'on était là quoi
c'est juste physique tu vas dormir et tu
vas manger parce que parce qu'il faut
pour tenir dans la durée mais c'est du
plaisir intense le bateau il
bon ça s'arrête jamais quoi il est sûr
l'ombre de la vague et tous et c'est
juste génial les sensations passées ces
des bateaux incroyable
[Musique]